[Musique]
c'est une agression d'une extrême
violence dont bernard tapie et sa femme
dominique ont été victimes dans leur
résidence secondaire à combs-la-ville en
seine-et-marne dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche
bernard tapie et son épouse ont été
violentés lors d'un cambriolage dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche ou et de goût
et séquestrés par leurs agresseurs
le couple a été pillé par une bande bien
organisée de quatre malfaiteurs alors
qu'on sait que l'état de santé de
bernard tapie est très fragile en raison
du cancer contre lequel il se bat depuis
plusieurs années les agresseurs ont
frappé sans pitié
sa femme dominique 70 ans a même été
traînée par les cheveux dans plusieurs
pièces de la maison avant de parvenir à
prendre la fuite et prévenir les voisins
afin de lancer l' alerte ce soir
stéphane tapie revient sur la soirée
d'horreur qu'on vécu bernard tapie son
père et dominique mercy mon stéphane
d'amour mon frérot date la c6 est très
content de te voir aujourd'hui parce que
j'étais inquiet hier quand j'ai appris
ça et voilà et j'ai eu des nouvelles
assez vite juste c'est vrai que je
retourne été choqué hier quand on a
appelé tagil je sais que tu es
bouleversé des thèmes beaucoup bernard
j'adore est bouleversée par la violence
par le le côté mais presque barbare de
l'agression un homme qui souffre son
épouse était franchement bouleversé le
jeu hyper ému mais c'était dans l'aérien
de plus abject de que de s'attaquer
physiquement un homme qui se bat contre
la maladie à sa femme les photos qu'on a
vues elles sont absolument abjecte cc
c'est mon tour justement on va en parler
avec avec stéphane alors déjà comment
ils vont bernard et d'au mieux
aujourd'hui un mieux au jas ça va déjà
un peu mieux dans et ça va bien mieux
physiquement ça va moins bien face à va
toujours pas terrible moralement mais
bon c'est dur c'est dur c'est dur mais
tu vois ce que disait gilles il ya il ya
une solidarité magnifique de certaines
personnes et et ça aide beaucoup
alors déjà que nous les proches qu'on
soit là et puis et puis les anonymes les
moins anonymes et et à ce moment là tu
te dis mais il ya d'autres gens qui
vivent ça c'est qu'ils n'ont pas cette
chance
entre guillemets d'être dans la lumière
et qui doivent une fois que les plats
pauline se referme la porte ils doivent
vivre dans leur maison et ils n'ont pas
la possibilité de parler de s'exprimer
de d'extérioriser systè que leur propre
entourage qui lui même et est marqué et
choqué donc
et voilà c'est plus à ces gens là
aujourd'hui qu'on pense paradoxalement
c'est rien de le dire
stéphane juste pendant ça arrive tous
les jours à bien ce moment c'est vrai
mais personne n'est malheureusement ces
gens là se retrouvent seuls quoi sans la
parole c'était stéphane toi comment tu
apprends ce qui s'est passé c'est c'est
ton papa qui t'appelle oui il m'a appelé
dans la nuit pendant la nuit alors tu
vois un appel à quelle heure il a
commencé à m'appeler haworth maska place
à trois heures du matin c'est que ton
papa déjà été malades aussi que berlin à
trois heures du matin tu vois on appelle
de ton père tu es jacquet study dans ta
tête
ben je dormais donc j'ai pas vu as tu as
pas vu le succès découvre alors la mèche
les découverts à 6h30 6h30 tu vois que
ton père t'a appelé plusieurs fois où tu
vois pas non parce que quand je me lève
je n'allume pas mon téléphone mois
d'avril bref voilà je vais je prends mon
café et je me mets devant la télé comme
tous les matchs à la télé et oui je la
prends comme ça et c'est fait et ma
femme me dit mais vite vite viens voir
ce qui se passe et la j'allume le
téléphone et joie 172 appelle les
messages par tous des amis beaucoup
d'amis et voilà mais c'est dur ouais tu
vois d'un coup à la télé c'est toi le
café a du mal à passer
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
exactement donc bernard il est parti et
donc avec ta ta lumière dans son et son
départ avec son épouse dans sa maison de
campagne
ils étaient tous les deux ils étaient
tous les deux le soir
ouais la journée il y avait il y avait
mon frère ma soeur je sais puis à veille
avait un des deux qui étaient là et mon
frère devait dormir là bas et finalement
il est rentré et meshes était
ultra-surveillé mon avis donc pas ce
qu'ils ont vu les allers retours et en
plus ils vont pas tous les week-ends et
ils y vont parfois juste la journée pas
le soir donc c'était ultra préparer
ultra préparer il ya plein d'autres
ce qui pose la question qu'ils hissent
bernard tapie il n'y a pas de sécurité
de services de sécurité avec lui bah non
il se déplace tout seul il en aurait
donc il ya plein de gens qui se posent
la question je te le dis qu'ils sont
posés la question qui ont dit c'est
c'est incroyable que bernard tapie n'est
pas de services de sécurité mais pour
quoi faire et avec des gens
bienveillants normalement c'est vrai
mais bon vous regarde pas toujours et e
donc là c'est dans la nuit quoi 3 heures
du matin non lui s'est réveillé à minuit
et demi une heure et demie d'accord
c'est en train de dormir les eaux dans
la dans la misère tous les deux et il se
fout à veiller avec light dans les yeux
coups de batte directs indirects
ils savaient qu'ils allaient chercher
ton par ben oui oui j'étais pas étonné
voilà soit lui est pas par hasard
non c'était pas un hasard il savait que
c'est qu'ils allaient et il avait cette
espèce d'obsession qui hantent
apparemment beaucoup de monde c'est de
savoir où était le coffre fort il paraît
donc là il s'attaque d'abord à ton papa
ou d'abord atteint d'abord à vont perdre
le mettre ko ils tempèrent leur a pas
dit qu'ils étaient malades ou non mis ko
d'entrée pour être sûr qu'il bouge pas
trop et après s'occuper de ma belle-mère
qui est qui et a été pareil réveillé
après l'a été c'est que les deux ont été
attachées mon père a été attaché départ
les mains et les pieds au bout du lit et
ma mère ils ont attaché les mains et il
l'a traînée dans la maison par les
cheveux en en lui hurlant de de montrer
où était le coffre qui amènera de coffre
et à chaque fois qu'elle répondait non
elle en prenait ont l'impression d'être
au moyen-âge incroyable c'est maintenant
les agressions c'est la barbarie
donc là hamon elle leur dit pas qu'il ya
pas de coffre tient assez bas si oui il
y en a pas mais c'est pas grave ils sont
persuadés qu'il y en a donc oui ça dure
trois quarts d'heure comme ça sur trois
quarts d'heure un moment ils comprennent
qu apparemment pas de coffre ou est ce
qu'il ne sait pas qui remettent ils
l'auront met tellement plein la tronche
qu'isis qu'à la fin on forcément pas
donc voilà ils partent avec juste
montrez une balle quoi ils étaient 4 4
pas très jeune par et il sait ce que tu
la trentaine
papa pas des voix de jeunes + voix
trentaine mais dont on n'a parlé que ton
papa quand il a s'est retrouvé à 00h30
avec une lampe devant lui qu'est ce qui
s'est dit d'abord il a essayé de se
défaire pour défendre sa femme c'est
terrible pour lui ils entendent et sa
femme créée dans les couloirs et nuit
était attachée au pied du lit pouvais
pas bouger donc c'était terrible après
bas il y en a qui qui qui finissent par
mourir sous les coups eux non il faut
garder positive de ça voilà c'est que
ils les ont laissés en vie et à l'aura
ici il partait il les laisse parents
vivent les gens est ce que est ce que
c'est vrai que tu as ta belle mère a
voulu protéger aussi ton papa elle a dit
voilà bce il ya là des ce2 tranquille et
c'est moi qui vais vous dire ce qui est
vous voulez et et des problème c'est
qu'en plus il après un coude à la tête
et comme il a une nouvelle tumeur dans
la tête il avait il avait très peur que
la tumeur expose donc elle a voulu
prendre tout de suite sa défense voilà
comme je suis toujours dit c est le
héros c'est il lui disait quoi ils lui
ont dit moment ils ont dit non ils en
appelaient par par son nom ils ont dit
on sait que bernard tapie ou pas du tout
retrait du dossard et parce qu'on peut
avoir des gens qui voient là qu'ils
savaient très bien chez qui ils étaient
seize mois mais il est il à une mauvaise
information je croyais comme un coffre
en fait mais c'est fait partie du
fantasme de tout paris ça de toute la
france et de tous les médias il ya des
coffres forcément planqué chez tapis ben
voila voila tu n'as pas pour une fois
ils auront découvert que vraiment ingrat
oui jean miche avait d'autant plus
désolant ce qui faisait parce qu'ils
sont venus ils seront très par la seule
fenêtre qu'il n'y avait pas d'alarmé
paraît-il dans la maison c'est la chance
de ta soeur où il n'y avait pas d'alarmé
c'est qu'il ne sait-on frères callewaert
mills à la télévision donc il savait des
amis et fait des repérages avant ils
savaient très bien ce qu'ils étaient
toutes les fenêtres sont équipés de
capteurs
une sauf une le calvaire a duré 45
minutes
et c'est par là qu'ils sont entrain
activement et s'il ne fallait pas facile
d'accès ah ouais ouais donc iséries
c'était bien enseignera le wii wheel
connaissez bien ou bien ce qu'ils
faisaient et c'était bien enseigner sauf
sur un truc c'est qu'il ait pas de
coffre voilà l'essentiel donc bon c'est
c'est ça juste il ya plein de gens qui
qui se demandent pourquoi ton papa a
refusé d'aller à l'hôpital
pourquoi ce qu'on va revoir les photos
c'est vrai que pour quoi choquer tout
c'est onfray rousset qui a voulu que
montrer de photos donc c'est un belle
mère et ton père et bernard il c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué de les regarder
je comprends stefan gp anglais mais
c'est bon c'est ce que tu m'a dit tu
m'as dit il n'a pas voulu y aller parce
que parce que voilà il voulait que ce
soit son médecin sous qui regarde si ces
tumeurs avait pas bougé c'est voilà
c'est tout la pas voulu y aller n'a pas
voulu dire et quand tu m'as dit un truc
au téléphone aussi tu m'as dit c'est
très dur de voir mon père dans cet état
c'est aussi très dur de voir ma belle
mère parce que là c'est très dur où est
de le voir lui dans cet état mais tu
sais l'espèce de 2,2 réflexe je te lis
brossé un mec on s'est tous un peu
battus on a tous pris d'être à temps en
temps tu vois on sait tous mais là tu
vois une femme et tu te dis comment
l'être humain peut s'acharner à ce point
là sur une femme parce que c'est
c'est horrible je jure c'est horrible de
s'acharner comme ça sur une femme
je comprends pas comment on arrive à
avoir ce réflexe de porter des coups
aussi violent à une femme déjà un homme
âgé atteint de la maladie c'est bon mais
ça reste un homme tu vois tu je sais pas
d'y être
comment t'expliquer mon inconscient me
fait dire face à ma beaucoup plus choqué
en voyant ma belle-mère que mon père
c'est sain c'est ce que tu dises reda
madi cc savait très bien qu'on me tape
on lui parlerai pas mais qu'en voyant sa
femme souffrir il parle il pourrait
peut-être parler et c'est un moyen de
pression j'en sais rien peut-être mais
enfin
c'est il n'y a pas d'explication à la
barbarie dont il ya une pression pour le
raisonnement je ne capte pas et et voilà
ils sont ils sont partis de la maison
directement ils sont non il ya eu
d'abord l'enquète de la police
judiciaire puis sous parties après vers
15h en ambulance pour qu'il soit sous
surveillance quand même parce que tony
rossi n'a pas voulu aller à l'hôpital
voulait rester à vie et aller mal à
aller allez-vous leur réserve tout de
suite c'est que je sens des retours pour
rester avec eux oui auprès de bernard
oui et donc qu'ils sont entrés hier
après midi à paris en ambulance pour
être joué pourquoi pourquoi au moment où
au bout de 45 minutes quand ils me
demandent où ils cochent wilks of wheels
coffre cesser ces quatre cambrioleurs
qu'est ce qui les a fait partir je pense
qu'ils ont compris comme dit jean michel
ils ont tellement tapé sur ma belle-mère
pour faire avouer qu'il se soit qu' il
ya ils ont compris qu à un moment donné
là il pour moi rien obtenir et qui
n'avait pas finalement de coffre ok
l'arrivée ces deux mondes de luxe les
boucles d'oreilles et les bracelets non
seulement des boucles d'oreilles et des
bracelets bagues ses délires c'est
incroyable cette histoire c'est fou
alors il aujourd'hui elle en est où
l'enquète s'agissait pas apparemment
c'est le parquet de paris qui a décidé
de prendre l'affairé en main
ce qui pose mais juge dans les 1 à 10
heureusement ils ont bien gants sur
place
j'espère que grâce à un grand ou
peut-être trouvé des traces adn peut
être monté jusqu'à l'équipe espère
gilles verdez effectivement la police
judiciaire il ya une unité spécialisée
dans la délinquance de bande organisée
il soupçonne de longs préparatifs une
bande organisée donc ils vont essayer
d'abord par des interrogatoires et la
police scientifique a essayé de
recueillir des tanins disent voilà il ya
mobilisation générale pour retrouver les
coupables
sans doute des gens très préparée et
très professionnelle très orgueilleux il
s'agit de mauvaise foi jeu stéphane
qu'on abat préparer
sûrement mais
en avant mais et superbad la forme est
donc préparation oui c'est évident qu'il
ya eu une préparation mais mais ces
leggings en plus
stéphane qu'est ce qui se dit tonton
papa aujourd'hui bernard parce que en ce
moment c'est vrai que je sais que
c'était pas la fin de vos visions c'est
un peu compliqué c'est incroyable tout
ce qui lui arrive
qu'est ce qui t'a dit 'est-ce qu'il as
qu'il il se bat encore et ce qui
évidemment évidemment c'est ça que moi
je me suis dit c'est incroyable parce
que il y encore là ben il a encore la
date
ils ont eu envie d'en baisser ma ou je
ne sais pas en ville et il est il se bat
il n'a chauriens et il ya ça qui lui
tombe sur la tête encore en plus ouais
c'est ici c'est incroyable qu'est ce qui
t'a dit bon on a la chance d'être encore
vivant
voilà on a la chance d'être encore
vivant de pas avoir de marque qui
resteront à vie et puis voilà
ils ont utilisé des objets non content
d'en donc bas au moins ils n'auront pas
de cicatrice ils ont sûrement des
cicatrices des battes de baseball
apparemment mais il pas trop sûr c'était
débatu des matraques fait c'est quand tu
prends un coup dans la tête c'était quoi
tu demande pas donc voilà aujourd'hui il
est encore en vie et et puisqu'ils ont
été menacé plusieurs fois de si tu
parles pas je te brûle se met le feu
mais mais voilà donc ce encore en vie
ils sont contents de l'être et le combat
reprend et continue c'est cela c'est
incroyable et puis tout de suite c'est
nous on a la chance où l on a la chance
sur rien on peut s'exprimer on peut
s'extérioriser on a des gens qui nous
appellent les potes qui nous appelle dsk
le président emmanuel m'apprend appelé
ton papa oui
alors il est passé par mois oui parce
qu'il n'avait pas de téléphone est
d'accord il est appelé donc ouais pour
te tout le monde doit te demander
comment commence à les way il a été
adorable et très humain pas dans la
posture politique du tout ça du tout du
tout oui oui
au delà des bleus ce qui est terrible
c'est le traumatisme psychologique tout
l'espoir qu'on vous endormez vous avez
le souvenir de ce cauchemar de vous
faire réveiller qu'une torche électrique
dans les yeux comme ça je vous trouver
le sommeil après sa lettre explique mais
c'est je pense à vue mais cette je prie
pour qu'ils arrivent à dormir parce que
ça doit être une épreuve damian retire
alors arthur tortue ce matin dia ton
demi frère laurent tapie qui a poussé un
coup de gueule contre les critiques ont
émané de la ram en 2000 frères sas et
seraient frères pardon excusez de ça
veut rien dire mais voilà voilà qui ont
émané de la gauche ou de la droite après
l'agression dont a été victime bernard
tapie et sa femme dominique est c'est
vrai que ça moi vraiment ils
souhaitaient qu'elle si j'ai vu des
tweets et notamment je me dis j'en
messieurs c'est on ne peut pas faire des
choses comme ça après une agression
c'est ça c'est c'est pas possible
regardez les photos pour moi c'est un
moyen de les renvoyer dos-à-dos terre
que l'on a les extrémistes de gauche qui
disent bah voilà ce que c'est que
d'avoir des résidences secondaires des
bijoux des montres etc
en gros bien fait pour vous et ceux de
droite qui lisent d' extrêmement hâte
qu'ils disent à bata bonne mine tapie
qui défendrait l'immigration c'est des
immigrés qui tombe quittant volée alors
que je vois pas en quoi le fait que leur
peau soit foncé prêt permet
immédiatement dire que c'est des
immigrés l'idée d'un corps en faisant
comme d'habitude l'amalgamé immédiat
entre les deux donc j'espère que ces
photos là vont leur permettent de se
voir dans toute leur imbécillité c'est
bien le frérot et puis y
il faut juste lui répondre un truc alors
on va revoir le tweet de deux jours
médias sont là bien sûr les agresseurs
de mera tapis sont quatre dont trois
africains et un de type nord-africain le
même bernard tapie qui accusé jean marie
le pen ce mensonge sur le lien entre
insécurité invasion de battoir il est
aujourd'hui rattrapé par la réalité bon
état bution sage ancien dj
j'ai juste l'impression de salut faire
c'est qu'ils se souviennent d'eux qui a
sauvé les gens dans l'hyper cacher sur
les attentats de charlie hebdo bien sûr
voilà c'était un immigré nord africains
c'est vrai donc l'or suit les valeurs
ici qui a été naturalisé d'ailleurs été
naturalisé l'adorent son geste messia
pas chez toi en taille et surtout les
autres tweets aussi on a vu des tweets
comme l'a dit tonton frère de gens qui
disaient voilà cccc ces gens qui ont des
mets résidents secondaires avec des
bijoux avec c'est incroyable d'entendre
ça c'est une minorité
c'est vraiment ces minorités j'ai
vraiment vu beaucoup plus de
bienveillant et bien sûr que tu que ces
gens là qui mérite même pas qu'on lors
qu'on leur réponde ce 10 mai siad qu'ils
allaient voir à l'hyper cacher s'il
n'était pas content qu'il y ait un
immigré nord africain pour les sauver
voilà donc c'est des amalgames à la con
qui j lo et je trouve que la famille est
digne ce que je suis
la famille est digne dans la dans la
dans l'extrême douleur dans le schéma
sais c'est que je sais que vous êtes
vous êtes très proche de ce ver n'a pas
aussi c'était la famille donc j'ai du
mal à du mal je trouve qu'ils sont d'une
extrême dignité dans la violence de ce
qu'ils ont vécu et ça ajoute encore à
l'émotion qui est une émotion
à part quelques imbéciles tout le monde
est avec vous totalement gelos et vous
avez une relation particulière avec
bernard tapie
quand vous avez appris ça vous depuis
que j'ai appris ça c'est comme si
c'était ma famille comme si comme si
c'étaient mes parents je suis
bouleversée c'est horrible de faire ça
c'est horrible horrible horrible l'appât
du gain ce que c'est moi mais voilà il
ya plein de gens il ya plein de gens à
qui ça arrive et qui ont voilà pas eu
assez de chance d'avoir tout ce soutien
parce qu'un soutien comme ça qu'ils
soient d'anonymes sur les réseaux pour
le coup une fois pour une fois les
réseaux basis était bienveillant et puis
le président ça fait du bien ça fait du
bien de te sentir aimée
après avoir eu cette violence est là tu
te dis merde il ya quand même d'autres
gens à qui ça arrive et ils n'ont pas
cette bienveillance là donc il faut il
faut penser à eux il faut surtout penser
à eux pas se plaindre nous et ça va ils
sont rentrés à la maison c'est des coups
et basses et des coûts c'est des coups
quelques coups de plus ils font plus mal
cela physiquement au départ après c'est
un peu moralement mais bon il faut
penser à ces gens acquis qui ont pas la
chance de que nous on a entre guillemets
d'être aussi bien en tout est faux au
jour d'aujourd'hui il ya forcément un
traumatisme
bernard et dominique ils sont aux frais
des mesures de sécurité ils ont raison
il ya dix normales comme dans non non
ils ont pu dormir hier soir
non je t'ai compliqué compliqué de
compliqué mais je sais que le président
a mis en place un système de sécurité de
son fait lui qui l'a décidé personne ne
lui a demandé
ok manière veillant de cette série par
bienveillance
voilà et madame macron a été très classe
elle vous à vous l'avez eu plusieurs
fois et c'est une grande dame pour
prendre des nouvelles a appris que wave
c'est vraiment une grande dame et aucun
racolage politique là dedans c'est vrai
que c'est alors très sincèrement close
c'est vraiment une grande sommes là
c'est juste il on vous fait de la
politique ils ont juste fait leur
travail
la réaction qu'on aurait nettoyé
l'humanité exactement exactement mais
même et c'est bon c'est vrai il ya eu
plein de gens d'autres partis qui m'ont
appelé où j'étais assez étonné parce que
parce que j'y trouve ça a juste le titre
inadmissible donc il ya les voilà c'est
cette solidarité
il faudrait mettre en place pour les
victimes anonymes qui eux n'ont pas
cette chance là justement stéphane oui
ton témoignage est très fort ce soir
qu'est ce que tu as à dire oh
qu'est-ce qu'on va dire à ses agresseurs
parce que c'est vrai que quand on est de
faire un petit tour à marseille jusqu'à
48 heures aux baumettes
quand on voit son bras comme ça
forcément tête m tu me connais je
connais tu me connais ça bout j'avais
envie de tout péter
je sais pas j'avais tu as toujours away
bah ouais tu as pu éteindre le téléphone
de mieux comment si mais j'en ai pris un
autre exactement j'en ai pris un autre
de secours ouais mais c'est leur vie si
la journée 7 répondent qu'il dit qu'il
aurait aimé s'expliquer voilà sur ce
qu'il a dit voilà on n'a pas trop envie
en fait est que apparemment voilà voilà
voilà
il dit ce qu'il veut monsieur c'est bon
là en tout cas stéphane merci d'avoir
été là mais tu es comme tu disais mon
frère donc chez compte msn et ont fait
d'énormes bisou à bernard et dominique
voilà et on t'aime et tu reviens nous
voir quand tu veux bien entendu ici
c'est ces sétois